[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tevez 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter et débattre des sujets qui font
l'actualité
20% des élèves maîtrisent mal les
savoirs fondamentaux à la sortie de
l'école primaire
une donnée qui a poussé emmanuel macron
a annoncé que jusqu'à l'été 2022 la
lecture serait grande cause nationale
mais y at-il d intérêt pour la lecture
on en parle avec nos invités béatrice
piron bonsoir vous êtes député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines et vous
êtes membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
éric allain jeunesse bonsoir bonsoir il
est vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la culture et
laurent garin bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
gérant de la ville de la librairie part
dans le pavé du canal établissements
indépendants à montigny le bretonneux
béatrice piron un an pour mettre la
lecture en avant est ce que ça suffira
ou bien écouter c'est déjà mieux que de
ne pas l'avoir fait et je crois qu'il
n'y a pas que cette année ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on travaille sur la
lecture notamment à lui
le plan bibliothèque il ya déjà
plusieurs actions donc c'est un
renforcement de ce qu'on faisait déjà
pour la lecture je vois plutôt à ce sens
là alors cette grande cause a
principalement touché les élèves de la
primaire au lycée
mais le manque de lecture se fait
ressentir à tous les âges selon un
article de ouest france en 1988
73% des français de 15 ans et plus
lisent et au moins un livre dans l'année
ils sont 62% en 2019
comment vous l'expliquez madame pire ou
alors si vous avez pris des chiffres
j'en avais trouvé d'autres plutôt sur
l'année 2020 je sais pas si on veut
comparer vraiment une année avec une
autre peut-être que les livres les
legends livre mon lisent moins de livres
mais une autre et utilisent à fond et
plus jusqu'au bout plus souvent qu'avant
donc avant de commencer des livres les
abandonner en cours de route maintenant
quand il commence au lien vivant
jusqu'au bout
c'est un progrès sur ce sujet là mais je
pense qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de sous
forme de lecture différente aujourd'hui
on se focalise sur la lecture des romans
ou des livres papier mais l'important
c'est que les gens lisent de façon
globale et l'habitude de lire donc moi
je travaille beaucoup avec le groupe
d'étude donc sur l'illettrisme et donc
les gens qui sont le plus en difficulté
qui eux justement ne lis pas beaucoup je
crois que il faut les entraîner à lire
parce que on a besoin de la lecture tous
les jours et pas uniquement pour la
lecture plaisir la lecture loisirs que
l'on fait avec un livre sur sa table de
nuit
on a aussi professionnellement besoin de
lire pour le s'informer pour aller voter
pour pour travailler pour lire des
consignes de sécurité donc je crois que
la lecture est tous les jours est
malheureusement en france hier pour
beaucoup trop de personnes qui sont
handicapés ou qui sont en difficulté par
rapport à cette lecture et si on veut
renforcer la lecture au niveau des
jeunes
c'est pour que justement après dans leur
vie d'adulte qui soit beaucoup plus à
l'aise alors parmi l'accès à la lecture
il ya les bibliothèques 27 % d'électeurs
y emprunte des ouvrages
éric allain jeunesse est ce que les
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parviennent à
attirer du public
ah oui incontestablement le réseau des
médiathèques attire un public nombreux
et fidèle proportion de d'abonnés qui
est importante sur le territoire plus
importante d'ailleurs que sur leur sur
le territoire national je dois rendre
hommage aussi au dynamisme du réseau des
médiathèques et de l'ensemble d'ailleurs
des structures culturelles de
l'agglomération par rapport justement à
la lecture qui font qu'aujourd'hui le
public s'intéresse de plus en plus à la
lecture des événements sont faits autour
de la lecture par exemple je citerai un
événement qui a lieu en ce moment à
retirant livre qui se passe donc
actuellement sur un ensemble de lieux de
l'agglomération et qui associe notamment
des libraires les associations le cas
des artistes des auteurs le réseau des
médiathèques bien évidemment mais aussi
le musée de la ville et la commanderie
avec tout un tout un certain nombre
d'activités qui tourne autour de la
lecture et sur l'ensemble des douze
communes de l'agglomération donc oui le
réseau billetech et est très très
impliqué on a un réseau maintenant qui
est qu'il ya quasiment finalisé son
uniformisation depuis l'intégration des
cinq nouvelles le villes de
l'agglomération avec des possibilités
qui sont extrêmement intéressants je
prends pour exemple le fait que vous
pouvez commander un ouvrage dans une
médiathèque et puis en prendre livraison
au niveau de la médiathèque qui se
trouve près de chez vous donc s'il
ouvrages ni l'épave
vous pouvez le faire venir et vous avez
aussi tous les tous les tous les
services de la médiathèque et de 2 de
l'offre numérique aussi mais aussi bien
évidemment le support papier qui est qui
est important parce qu'il ya un je
croyais à une relation physique nos
lectures ya pas que ça fait travailler
l'imaginaire mais en même temps tournait
les pages c'est aussi avoir une relation
un peu charnel avec le livre donc moi je
suis très attaché à cette à cette
dimension-là de la lecture qui est
un dialogue singulier avec le livre est
justement se rapporte à gré avec le
livre laurent gars en tant que libraire
est ce que vous avez vu les ventes
chuter ou peut-être évoluer dans votre
métier
alors nous c'est plutôt évolué et moi
j'ai une vision très très optimiste et
très joyeuse de la situation actuelle
les tons par le oui mais les gens se
sont donnés le temps de lire et de
revenir un peu à l'essentiel donc les
commerces locaux nous on a pu vivre de
son confident comme on a pu mais on en
est sorti plutôt grandi dans le sens où
on a eu un vrai essor de la part du
public et notre client de suivi
d'attention de savoir comment se porter
et ensuite le livre est resté un objet
très très attendu et comme il est à
chaque fois donc au mois de décembre sur
les fêtes de noël on a pu vivre un bon
mois de décembre et ensuite sur l'année
2010 21 on a senti vraiment qu'il y
avait tous cet engouement il a réussi à
durer et il dure encore là aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui là maintenant on est
passé sur le pass culture donc un
système qui vient d'être mis en place
sur la fin mais pour tous les jeunes de
18 ans mais en fait voilà le public est
au rendez vous donc les libraires
également toutes les librairies
indépendantes on s'est mis en ordre de
marche pour poursuivre ce mouvement là
donc non non c'est une vision très très
optimiste de la situation que nous on a
libre et indépendant madame fille rousse
et y réagir oui je pense vous avez
commencé l'émission en parlant d'une
anémique de grande cause nationale mais
ça fait depuis plusieurs années qu'on
essaie quand même d'encourager la
lecture et notamment avec les séances
quart d'heure lecture dans les écoles
primaires dans les collèges où tout le
monde s'arrête pendant 15 minutes
donc pour lire y compris le personnel de
service ou les adultes pas uniquement
les enfants mais tout le monde doit lire
pendant 15 minutes simultanément et puis
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur donc le
pass culture qui a démarré donc dans le
département c'est avait été déjà
expérimenté les années passent et on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui donc sur les
300 euros clora donner aux jeunes la
plus grosse dépense main vers les livres
etc
ce première étape de 300 euros cette
année s complète l'année prochaine dans
par des ajouts qui vont être faits au
niveau des collégiens et des lycéens
donc dès le collège les élèves auront
donc 25 euros tous les ans puis 50 euros
puis après à 18 ans les 300 euros ce qui
représente un budget culture qui
pourront donc petit à petit s'approprier
et utiliser le régionalement et
localement victoire et dans les
librairies
monsieur gare à vous soutient quid donc
en fait ce pass culture nous a amené de
nouveau de nouveaux clients fait
vraiment toute une partie qu'on n'avait
pas l'habitude de voir en libre et donc
plein de jeunes qui arrivent ici qui
sont pas cons pas des codes compact y
voit là mais que sait très bien qu'il
rentre chez nous qu'ils voient un peu ce
qu'est la lecture ce qu'est le livre
qu'ils voient comment ça fonctionne et
non c'est vraiment une chose très très
bonne pour l'attrait et pour l'accès à
la lecture
or donc ce pass culture c'est vraiment
de très bonnes choses oui messieurs
finale zaïri âgées mais justement je
voulais vous avez que s'il ya aussi chez
vous lecture pour tous trois classes de
collège ont participé au dispositif
cette année il y a vraiment du lien à
l'agglomération entre les médiathèques
et les établissements scolaires
oui bien sûr on est tout à fait soucieux
de ce lien est évidemment il ya été
régulièrement des éclats ce qui viennent
dans les médiathèques pour se
familiariser justement avec avec quinze
ouvrages
donc oui bien sûr il ya un fort un fort
partenariat avec avec des scolaires du
territoire
moi je voulais revenir un petit peu sur
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
concernant donc un petit peu ce qu'on
vient de vivre le confinement la crise
sanitaire il semblerait donc je lisais
une étude doxa qui disait que justement
le confinement et une augmentation de la
lecture et je regardais un petit peu les
motivations de cette de ce retour à la
lecture qui intéresse amusant qui avait
lutté contre l'ennui bien évidemment
pour la majeure partie des gens mais
aussi se déconnecter de l'actualité ou
des réseaux sociaux
donc on voit un petit peu que le livre
qui était considéré au départ à monsieur
monsieur guérin est bien placé pour
savoir les librairies et effet rangé au
départ
les libraires étaient fermées il ya eu
une attente forte du public et celle là
c'est cet acte militant du public qui a
vu la réouverture des librairies et
qu'il y a une vraiment une poussée mais
ça je trouve que c'est c'est s'est
incliné à l'optimisme et je vous rejoins
monsieur guérin je crois que le livre à
de la vidéo je crois que les librairies
ont des venir des médiathèques bien
évidemment parce qu'elle soit aussi une
source
on ne peut pas acheter tous les livres
mais on peut aussi prendre contact avec
la lecture par ce biais et je pense
aussi que nous avons en france 1 1 un
rapport différent au livre que peuvent
avoir par exemple nous les anglo saxons
moi j'ai eu la vague soir et la nuit ans
j'étais un peu choqué parce que sur les
poubelles il y avait des livres et je me
suis interrogé savoir qu'en fait le
livre est un produit consommation en
france c'est pas un produit de
consommation
il a presque une valeur patrimoniale on
se transmet des lignes je pense que
c'est évident c'est quelque chose qui
est important est que je crois que
l'utilisation de ce pass culture pour
acheter des livres on n'est pas des pas
innocente et signifie vraiment que non
seulement on veut s'approprier le
contenu mais on veut aussi s'approprier
l'objet donc je partage votre optimisme
suivre vous parlez de la lecture évasion
alors il ya certains lecteurs qui se
qualifie de petit lecteur d'autres de
grands lecteurs
les grands lecteurs c'est ce qu'ils
lisent plus de 20 livres par an et je
vous propose qu'on parte à la rencontre
de l'un d'entre eux catherine boucher le
professeur de lettres dans un collège
saint quentinois
mais la lecture est pour elle aussi un
plaisir privé regarder je vais regarder
la danse rayon feuilleter chercher
parcourir les rayons pour catherine
boucher dénicher un livre dans une
librairie est plus qu'une habitude c'est
un rituel
cette billancourt trois achète entre 3
et 15 ouvrages par mois ça représente un
endroit où je peux trouver des livres
que j'aime
des livres que je découvre des livres
que je peux faire découvrir aux autres
que ce soit ma famille mes amis mais
elle est important parce que c'est notre
jeu peut les toucher je suis vos
contacts ils sont présentés c'est beau
c'est calme
professeur de lettres dans un collège
fuyant courtois passionné de théâtre et
de poésie
catherine boucher a toujours aimé lire
jusqu'à ses 14 ans et environ un ouvrage
par jour avec une préférence pour le
roman elle ne s'interdit aucun genre et
rentre dans sa bulle
je dis toujours avant de dormir quelle
que soit l'heure à laquelle je me
coucher je vis toujours endormie et
ensuite je lis dans la journée dès que
je peux dès que j'ai un petit peu de
temps ça me détend c'est c'est plaisir
de retrouver les livres que j'aime je ça
me permet de préparer
tous mes cours que ce soit les cours
poser vos collègues que ce soit le
théâtre ça me permet de
de retrouver des connaissances des
émotions que je sais que je vais avoir
en reprenant tel livre catherine boucher
a transmis sa passion à ses proches tout
en respectant leur goût et leur rythme
les grands lecteurs comme catherine sont
principalement des femmes et les plus de
65 ans sont les plus représentés leurs
hangars 1 c'est un profil que vous
rencontrez beaucoup dans votre
établissement
oui alors oui bien sûr des gens qui sont
avec lesquels on apprend toujours
beaucoup de choses en fait des habitués
et il ya un vrai échange qui se crée
donc je connais très bien catherine on a
réussi à remonter quelques projets
ensemble
oui c'est un profil qui ont fréquemment
bien sûr mais oui allez je vous en prie
mais ce n'est pas que le seul profil
qu'on trouve maintenant librairie
également donc voilà il ya vraiment un
vrai tournant qui s'opèrent actuellement
sur les profils de lecteurs et ça on a
vu vraiment sur le post confinement
depuis le début de l'année on a vraiment
l'éventail et le chant des le panel de
des gens que l'on rencontre souvent
vraiment et c'est vraiment très
intéressant
oui briatte respirons j'avais trouvé
aussi que la crise la plus vide avait
modifié le comportement des lecteurs on
l'a on l'a un peu entendue malgré tout
34% des français surfent plus sur
internet qu avant l'épidémie 26% d'entre
eux sont plus sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce qu'il faut aider à retrouver des
automatismes d'ouvrir un ouvrage de deux
dalles et s'évader par l' ouvrage
justement après cette année difficile je
pense que les gens en ont chacun leurs
préférences ou leur rougir et que les
jeunes aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus
sur les écrans que les aînés mais j'irai
que c'est pas pour autant qu'ils qui
perdront tout contact avec la lecture
les romans on a des jeunes qui lisent
des mangas et qui en lisent souvent
aussi et je crois qu'il faut pas opposer
le livre papier à aa la lecture
numérique moi à titre personnel je lis
plusieurs heures par jour mais bien
souvent
des articles de presse et bien souvent
dématérialisée sur des écrans c'est
quand même de la lecture et à côté ça
quand je suis en vacances je prends un
livre papier parce que là je sais que je
vais pouvoir me plonger dedans et quand
j'en commence un j'aime bien le finir
rapidement donc il va me falloir l'après
midi entière donc ça c'est réservé à mes
périodes de congés mais celle important
que les gens aiment lire quelle que soit
la façon qu'ils choisissent de mon point
de vue et les câlins jeunesse aussi la
numérisation a été un point d'entrée à
l'agglomération pour pendant la crise
tout à fait bien sûr la numérisation a
permis beaucoup de choses notamment de
laisser la place au contenu qu'ils
n'étaient pas acccessibles physiquement
et à ce titre là je rejoins la députée
qui est qui qui qui est tout à fait
favorable à une lecture et l'utilisation
du numérique
je pense qu'on ne peut pas opposer les
deux il faut pas confondre la matière
est l'objet la matière c'est la lecture
si le contenu l'objet qui permet son
accès il veut être numérisée qui peut
être physique être en papier peu importe
ce qui est important c'est de lire
alors le petit bémol qu'on peut mettre
c'est vrai que si on met une tablette
avec un roman dans la main d'un enfant
peut-être bête il a tenté un moment
d'arrêter dire faire autre chose avec sa
tablette pc à la limite c'est peut-être
aussi le rôle des parents de de
circonscrire un petit peu les temps le
dédier à chaque activité
mais peu importe l'important je rejoint
l'alliance d'importance et de ligues
mineures
les médias font beaucoup d'animation on
l'a entendu laurent guérin vous même
dans votre établissement vous faites des
animations et des dédicaces
bien sûr ça c'est le modèle qu'on
connaît très bien mais il ya aussi des
rencontres voir des petits concerts
pourquoi vous avez mis ça en place
parce qu'on est un acteur culturel de
l'agglomération et que en tant qu acteur
culturel il faut s'ouvrir à plein de
choses quoi multiculturelle exactement
fin oui c'est ça donc on a reçu des
chorales on a reçu un slameur on a reçu
des associations qui permet des migrants
de l'accueil des migrants
tout dernièrement le week-end dernier on
a reçu victor dixen qui est un grand
auteur de littérature jeunesse voilà on
s'ouvre à plein de choses et donc on met
en place bas avec la bulle on a enfin un
plateau et un espace vraiment dédié à sa
pour recevoir confortablement les
associations ou les acteurs culturels de
que l'on apprécie donc voilà on est on
est plutôt est très content aussi de
d'ouvrir enfin ce lieu là à plein de
choses quoi plein de choses qu'on
apprécie nous et qui nous portent tout
au long de l'année et béatrice pire on
parlait du format mais il ya aussi le
genre qu'on lise un manga qu'on dise une
bande dessinée un comics un roman une
nouvelle c'est de la lecture pas pour
moi oui même une recette de cuisine si
la lecture giret et j'irai que les gens
sont autorisés à passer demande un type
de produit à un autre et où ils iront
progressivement je pense que les gens
qui parce que je m'intéresse surtout aux
gens qui sont un petit peu trop éloigné
de la lecture
vous la mettez en roman de zola ils vont
pas ils vont pas forcément accroché sur
un gros livre mais pourront être
intéressé au départ par par découvrir
des recettes de cuisine et des choses la
vie pratique et petit à petit nous irons
vers une bande dessinée vers une
histoire comique vers un recueil de
nouvelles qui feront au maximum 10 pas
chacune et petit à petit pourront aller
vers le livre et je crois qu'il faut
encourager nos jeunes à lire quel que
soit le
elle peut soit le type de lecture leur
gardien vous souhaitez réagir
oui enfin juste ne pas revenir sur les
animations il n'y a pas que les
animations dans la livrée il ya aussi
les animations
or le diwan donc on monte beaucoup de
passerelles avec le réseau des
médiathèques donc me vois faire par
exemple d'une présentation de la rentrée
littéraire à la médiathèque du canal
enfin voilà on essaye de jeter des
passerelles donc entre les différents
acteurs et on y arrive plutôt bien et il
ya une bonne état d'esprit il ya une
bonne voie une bonne énergie qui est qui
est en place sur l'agglomération pour
que la libre et ne soient pas juste un
commerce de détail qu'on arrive à faire
passer d'autres choses et tous ensemble
on arrive à monter des jolis projets
voilà je voulais juste ajuster éviter la
jeunesse vous souhaitiez vous aussi
réagir oui tout à fait je vais tout à
fait dans le sens de ce que dit monsieur
guérin c'est à dire que la lecture ne
peut pas être isolé de des autres
activités culturelles et c'est
extrêmement intéressant de pouvoir
justement mais les lectures musique de
permettre de rencontrer les auteurs
c'est très important rien qui côté
initiatique aussi dans la lecture vous
donner un livre à un enfant il ne pas
forcément aller il va pas aller
spontanément
si on ne lui n'est pas un petit peu le
pied à l'étrier donc je pense que toutes
ses activités je parlais tout à l'heure
de partir en livre avec tout ce mois qui
va être dédié à la lecture sur
l'ensemble des 60 du territoire de
l'agglomération va permettre bien
évidemment à tous ses enfants à tous ces
jeunes de prendre contact
on disait de retrouver la lecture mais
peut être aussi de la trouver pour ceux
qui n'ont pas forcément déjà trouvé et
et d'avoir envie de lire d'avoir envie
que de prendre un livre d'avoir envie de
faire autre chose que de consommer de
l'image comme malheureusement voit un
petit peu trop souvent
et comme c'est parfois un peu caricaturé
mais avec quand même une certaine
réalité pour certains
madame piron oui j'avais des coupeurs
change nous ça va j'ai cru voir que vous
souhaitiez réagir par rapport au dernier
cours d'eau oui juste ajouter qu on voit
effectivement important de pratiquer
parce qu'en fin de compte je vous
épargne et déjà plusieurs fois des gens
qui sont en situation d'illettrisme
il faut pas du tout confondre
l'illettrisme et l'analphabétisme ne
sont pas des gens qui n'ont pas appris à
lire sont des gens qui sont allés à
l'école et peut y parvenant souvent une
dizaine d'années et mais qui ont
désappris parce qu'en fin de compte si
on ne pratique pas on désapprend et peu
de gens le comprennent ça parce qu'on a
l'impression quand on lit tous les jours
que c'est quelque chose qu'on mette
refusera toute sa vie qu' on ne peut pas
perdre à lecture
mais si les gens qui sont un petit peu
en situation fragile qui ne lisent pas
couramment qui ont des difficultés on va
dire en sortant du de l'école primaire
ou en sortant du lycée et qui n'aiment
pas lire s'il passe on va dire peut-être
cinq ans dix ans sans lire ben ils
arriveront encore moins à lire que là où
était la dernière fois et donc il ya un
phénomène de désapprentissage donc c'est
pour ça qu'il est important que tout le
monde pratique un petit peu tous les
jours ou toutes les semaines
c'est en se forçait faut que ça soit du
plaisir mais il est important de lire
régulièrement
et justement on devient meilleur lecteur
plus on lit plus on progresse et le
plaisir se développe même beaucoup plus
tôt que la primaire ce même si on
apprend officiellement à lire au cp au
médiathèque de saint quentin en yvelines
il y a les comptes pour les tout petits
aussi on apprend dès les premiers mois
de sa vie à lire monsieur jeunesse
absolument oui tout à fait raison c'est
bien informée il ya notamment
l'événement la fête du conte qui a lieu
chaque année et puis dans le dans le
parcours de de partir en livre binya si
vous avez l'occasion de regarder le
programme que vous retrouvez donc soit
sur le site de saint quentin en yvelines
vous verrez qu'il ya de très nombreuses
activités destinées à vous tous petits
ou sous forme de lecture de contes de et
l'objectif c'est toujours de de faire
travailler l'imaginaire des enfants de
l'ue et les de les stimuler de les
amener
à ne pas être passifs face à des images
qu'ils reçoivent mais à faire travailler
leur imagination justement au travers de
la lecture de ces comptes qui pour
l'instant l'heure est fait mais qui
évidemment demain leur donneront envie
peu de prendre un livre dès qu'ils en
auront les capacités pour se replonger
dans cet univers du continent élective
je regarde on parlait tout à l'heure
avec le portrait de catherine boucher du
profil de vos clients
mais parmi les achats aussi ce que vous
voyez beaucoup d'achats de lecture
adulte ou finalement départ en cachette
pour leurs enfants
alors durant le confinement on a vu
beaucoup de littérature beaucoup de
fictions beaucoup de littérature de
l'imaginaire pour adultes et là c'est
plutôt la bande dessinée qui prend le
pas sur la fiction et la littérature
donc tous formats de bande dessinée il
ya enfin c'est tellement pléthorique au
niveau de la bande dessinée dont il ya
les romans graphiques les mangas le
enfin la bande dessinée franco belge
comme peu beaucoup la connaître mais il
ya vraiment
l'offre est telle que c'est là pour pour
nous c'est vraiment la bande dessinée
qui qui qui a pris le pas sur la
littérature actuellement mais je vous
propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots
cette société maintenant terminé merci
de nous avoir suivis c'était le dernier
numéro de cette saison les nombreux
événements partir en lille se retrouve
sur le site de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et je vous souhaite
un très bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]